freunde herzlich willkommen zu diesem
video ich sitze heute gemeinsam mit
sandra und dave und die beiden sind
meine mit krieger muss man schon fast
sagen für unser heutiges projekt ist so
ich habe alles bei five guys bestellt
ich habe gesehen dass wir die auch ein
video gemacht hat wo er bei 51 bestellt
wir haben das schon lange geplant war
ich wollte schon immer macht alles
weisenberger laden oder so bestellen und
heute ist ein traum wahrgeworden
das hier ist unsere bestellung also ganz
ordentlich bei uns gibt es nicht super
viele sachen also auch keine kooperation
geben ich super viele sachen sondern es
gibt zum beispiel hamburger cheeseburger
bacon cheeseburger und dann habe ich
eigentlich immer alles mit der
75-jährige gleiche bürger also erstmal
genau die magic war wir haben erdbeere
schoko und vanille was wollte ich muss
dazu sagen ich bin happy dass wir das
ganze machen ist ich bin froh dass air
max das bezahlt weil so ein shake
alleine kostet über 6 und ehrlich teuer
also heißt es wirklich teuer aber ist
auch eine erfahrung und special war auch
das erste mal fünf geist von sandra war
gemeinsam mit mir in berlin
also wir haben quasi alles anders ist
schon cool erst mal bewährt ich das ein
bisschen schlechter sein erstes mal
greift als mein erstes mal war ich habe
mein erstes mal viel spaß mit max in new
york kranke alte oder magic alleine
macht schon sehr weit
nach dem trinken würde bevor das essen
kommt finito da ist die ganze pracht
leute seht ihr dass es in 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 verschiedene sandwiches die wir testen
werden und die sind durchnummeriert
perfekter weise dementsprechend würde
ich sagen die nummer eins bacon
schießberg dem er geht nicht glaube ich
geht erst mal euren weg für mich ist es
eine vermisste nacht von 10
keine ahnung wo es auch manchmal nicht
die grünen hier typisch es ist die das
immerhin so alufolie einpacken und dass
der bürger so aussieht was bei anderen
bürger lehnen gefühlt so ein grund wer
das zurückzugeben was hier wirklich
gehört dazu also so sieht das ganze hier
ist es wirklich speziell also man könnte
sagen also manch einer könnte finden
dass das scheiße aussieht aber das
könnte so richtig freut sich auf ein
bisschen reue ich auch vor der kamera
wer das jetzt professionell teilen das
ganze hier zwei paris drauf und dann
wenn wir uns gemeinsam den ersten wissen
wo ich natürlich das besondere bei
freizeit ist man braucht und das ist
einfach so ein mann haben wir sozusagen
verstehen das ist so ein vielleicht das
ganze auch verträge ist unklug gewesen
für mich kann man sich mit dem besten
angebot becken cheeseburger von fünf da
ist krieg von jahrzehnts was würdest du
sagen wenn du hast ja auf dem mainburger
können was meinst du keiner beleidigt
mich nicht wenn du sagst fall klingt
also bei der fehlt halt der banken so
tun ja aber von der kruste dieser burger
bulette ist es also deswegen wie ein
kleiner geführt der zeitgeist bürger mit
einem smash perry das wäre bitter ich
wollte das so natürlich so form es
bleiben aber wir müssen natürlich
eigentlich mit einem bisschen abwarten
für mich ist eine neun von zehn einfach
auch weil es der einzige bürger ist den
ich selber immer bei fiat bestellt habe
und noch sehr fit worms ist das da
bestimmt noch irgendwas kommt was uns
richtig um da werde ich mich anschließen
wollen wir mal ab was exotisches gehen
und mit einem hot dog weitermachen das
ist hier heute die links und hot dogs
nummer vier ist ein kies sorgt hot dog
ist prinzipiell nicht sogar die bürger
oder was würdet ihr heute schon sehr
sehr geil aber auf jeden fall bürger
immer bürger und kein
okay das hat aber auch kraft aus preis
leistung ist hat die beim kehraus ja da
sind wir doch einen euro ein
ja wir dritteln auch unsere motto der
schmeckt irgendwie wie ein abendbrot
wieso brot mit einfach so gut mit dessen
technik heute auf ist im winter ist mir
so ein angebot nicht schlecht wenn wir
schlecht aber es ist besser als ein
klassischer rostock auf jeden fall ja
sehr sowie sowie support sonne
wir laden sie sagen auch drei alle
unsere bewerbung die mine hallnor wir
machen weiter mit dem preis kennt weiß
die sind so ein bisschen und würzig
gemisch und ich meine pommes auch bei
einem burger laden komplett wichtig
deshalb bin ich sehr gespannt wie sie
performen werden guter grund dafür dass
sie geliefert wurden oder dass wir sie
abgeholt hat dass die obersten glaube
ich gehört ich bin ich mal auf deine
meinung ist sie zum ersten mal
ich habe die perfekte gestaltung kennt
ihr das von süßkartoffeln pommes dass
die nice sind um also zu snacken aber
dass man davon nicht eine komplette
portion ersten gehörten genauso ist es
mit diesen dingen das stimmt ja da so
die salatsprossen da ist normal dass das
war noch mit in der tüte erstens muss
ich sagen diese mischung die wir da
drauf haben dies in diesen typischen
pommes gerührt denkt und hätte gegen
jade goody einfach ja denn die anderen
ja richtig geil dass wir sagen wir
hätten sie aber direkten vergleich
besser sagen ja gelb hat wieder glück
und trägt die obersten leute ich meine
zu diesem punkt ist auch wirklich noch
offensichtlich mal einfach nur noch
videos um geiles essen zu essen ok hat
lege ich direkt danach essen sollten bei
den konstanzer dem anderen sagen ja also
die schmecken jetzt übels neutral
bewerten doch wir werden zuerst die
kämpfe 466 ich finde immer noch geil
wir bewerten die anderen heiko h nur
sechs von uns hat ein bisschen salz
gefehlt vielleicht bei in meine
geschmacksnerven durch die cable preis
abgestimmten agieren was sagt er ich bin
der auch für mich
ja du liebst franken wir machen weiter
seit dem great die sandwich habe ich
auch schon häufig machst hast du mal
nicht gegessen oder aber hälfte schon
der erste wahllose male also bridges ist
eine wissenschaft und ich bin gespannt
was uns ausmacht hat ja auch noch nie
gegessen
okay das machen das machte in der
kolberger betrug mir aus ich glaube es
ist halt wirklich einfach nur einen
burger dann nimmst zurück wir haben es
in side aufgedreht damit das geile an
wohnt sehr schlau sehr sehr schlau und
jetzt kommt der große bridge ist es okay
glaube vom handling und so habe ich noch
nicht das beste gefühl der ist wirkt so
die mcdonald's frühstück auf den ersten
blick
daher sollten anders also man kann die
kalorien auf jeden fall besser und
beruhigen oder weil das sind all die
sachen die wirklich richtig schlimm sind
nur gefühlt einem burger also so
gebuttert angetaute post amerikanischer
käse und örtlich sogar 32
also das muss ja als 2 ich hätte mich
geärgert wenn ich dafür geld ausgegeben
also auf dem level ist
hier könnt ihr noch ich merke wir hätten
da freue ich mich ja der milchwerke
schon langsam wie es losgeht und langsam
ist schwer aber worauf habt ihr lust
habt ja dann gehen auf den hamburger
dass die 2
da fehlt schon mal weg und schied ist es
sieht schon anders
muss man wirklich sagen
gut sie wirklich selber aus jekyll was
ich meine wenn ich sage sieht so
amerikanisch auch ja das ist irgendwie
bisschen falsch ist dass deutschland so
aus dem laden zu erfreuen und nicht
dasselbe gefühl vielleicht ein bisschen
wie so dass alba phänomen was man auf
der wenn man alle auf der hütte trainers
ist ob kraft einer schmeckt anders wenn
man es auf der hütte ist trägt
meckenheim ich finde es fehlt was
schmeckt so mehr so bis zum best or
explain irgendwie so erst so richtig ja
so commerce die man ganz klar das sind
die wenn man so will irgendwie bald über
die du so die zuhörer so vorgeformte
teppich der überzeugt wirklich nicht
sein
3 die immer noch ich bin enttäuscht von
diesem bereich war vor zwei punkte
schlechter gewesen sein als ein grill
okay ja ihr habt ja gut vielleicht hätte
ich ein bisschen höher gehen können aber
ich finde man kauft oder braucht es zum
was trick wenig gesalzen ja das hat mich
wirklich gucken ob wir noch was gänzlich
neues haben auf unserer liste wir haben
blt sandwich was mein kopf ich sehe was
der grund dafür
alter schwede michael bay kind ist da
bitte drauftreten jetzt aber er wirklich
leute ja noch nie soviel bacon auch
irgendwas gesehen
irgendwie so ein frühstücks bürger
vielleicht nicht der bacon ist so heftig
die höhe der summe so eine textprobe
alter das ist so als würde man wenn man
kekse essen gefühlt so vom kreis schwer
im kommen
ich würde auch gerne doch was hat dir
gefällt der pop art gemacht nur noch 1
okay
es macht auch keinen sinn wir sind echt
langsam alle am limit und wir überlegen
uns gut was das letzte sein wird fünf
bacon skistock das becken kisdorf veggie
burger oder cheeseburger und der welt
ich habe ein bisschen papier wir schauen
uns an das was uns erwartet mit den
veggie burger öffnen was ist der weg
über ausnahmsweise ultra viel zeug drauf
machen hier den querschnitt bulette und
sandwiches vimpelcom lockt also der der
milchshake gibt ein paar jahren war ich
erst wenn man dann zwischen den seiten
schlug man denkt ja ich trink kurz was
nein du trinkst nicht goethe ist die
gerade motto nach dem ganzen was wir
bisher gegessen haben da ist ja wirklich
doch noch ein bisschen mehr gemüse darf
wirkt das fast so ein bisschen frech
oder die zwiebeln sind krass
volker schmeckt ein bisschen frech ist
eine sehr sehr sehr geile alternative
für den stalker vier sailer als länder
wäre so ein fake bedankt hat die
rheinbahn sicherlich sagen sonne scheint
durch nicht weniger
das durchbricht so ein bisschen das five
guys motiv das wirklich alles eins ist
hier hat so ein bisschen mehr diversität
drin allerdings auch als 60 personen
fressen aber ich bin schon hast du sehr
geil ist nicht nur sagen die bewertung
ist in 321 richtig das könnte mit das
beste gewinnen sein wobei neben der
erste 19 leute das war wirklich ein
video wie es mir schon immer gewünscht
habe ich hoffe es hat euch was macht wir
sehen uns im nächsten video wieder und
tat gut